what's up everybody my name is Jacob
klier and I'm a musician and I'm here to
answer some of your questions from the
internet this is instrument
[Music]
support this is a question from Rachel
gaza1 why does a hash piano have 88 keys
it is indeed the case that there are 88
keys on the piano should we listen to
them all one by
[Music]
one and over the last few hundred years
composers have sought an increasing
amount of range to work with in their
composition so this note here the C8
this is 4,186 Herz which is actually a
very high note and this note here which
is a z is 27.5 Herz which is a very low
note human beings can hear from about 20
Herz to about 16,000 htz which is a
great deal of range so the piano covers
like a a hefty amount of that so yeah 88
keys and and much Discovery to be found
here is a question about guitars here's
a guitar this question is from at hater
why does holes in Guitar exist they are
annoying when Things fall into them it
is actually annoying I've lost plenty of
my belongings I've lost passport Keys
all sort of stuff and when I play a
chord the whole body of this instrument
is vibrating the best sound is actually
kind of inside the
instrument a holding guitar existed that
the sound can project a question from at
teacher on topic how does a theramin
make music is it through science or from
being haunted valid valid question this
in fact this is a theramin and to rig
this up I think I just need this which
is one of two antenna that makes this
work I'm going to put this into here ah
and then powers on the back
right okay so the way this instrument
works is by generating two
electromagnetic fields from two antenna
so this is one antenna and this is the
other down here this one controls volume
so the further my hand gets away from
this the louder the sound and this
one
controls pitch which is kind of
neat I'm not a masterful
player but it's it's in that process
that you generate notes and things which
is beautiful our bodies conduct
electricity what these antenna are
measuring are essentially the the
electricity that our bodies are
conducting so it's a kind of a beautiful
process of of measuring and proximity
and things like that but anyway maybe
they're also haunted this this is
freaking me out slightly at Papa Gibby
please what is treble and there's not
even a question mark at the end of this
question so it's really kind of quite
candid treble is the word that we give
to the very high sounds in music you
have bass
like all those low sounds that that
those base frequencies got some
frequencies in the middle these ones and
up here this is this is the the the
treble end of the sounds Yeah so
basically treble is high I could have
just said that treble is high okay
here's a question from at peculia yet
real guess that's me too do people know
what a Rhythm Section does people do
know what a Rhythm Section does I know
what rythm section does a Rhythm Section
is the the part of the the band or the
part of The Ensemble that that plays the
kind of the underlying rhythmic parts
that create the body the bed of the
sound over which other things can happen
so say you're in a big band The Rhythm
Section comprises of the drummer and the
bass player the guitar player and the
piano player primarily and that provides
the underbelly of all of those horns
flutes trumpets trombones whatever you
you have in your big band The Rhythm
Section is the part that like holds down
the for here's a question that I endorse
the asking of explain to me dot dot dot
the concept of microtones do we ever use
them in western music it does show up in
popular music especially with
instruments like the guitar you can bend
notes on the guitar and trumpets
clarinet and flutes and things like this
where you you have control over where
you put your finger where you place the
note an easy way to explain microtones
is through a game that I often play just
for fun I like playing games for fun you
take two notes G and
E how many notes can you fit between
these two notes on the
piano there are two notes
between right
what happens if we try and squeeze in
more
notes
right you go forever these are all
Micron these are notes that you can't
find in the piano here's a question from
piss Kink wow what a username bro why do
people even play bass you can't even
hear that laugh my ass off that's
crazy to me okay well let's let's get
let's get this actually a base here
handy bass play is extremely important
in music as a bass player you could you
can be the
[Music]
drummer you can play
melodies and you can also play
[Music]
chords so the bass is are beautiful and
very important instrument in in music
and I'm a huge fan of the Bass from at
hexa portal why do minor chords sound
sad I would probably say that I think
the reason why minor chords potentially
sound sad is that a minor chord is
actually an exact reflection of the
relationships of a major chord so a
major chord sounds like this this is e
major one of my good friends and that is
E minor another one of my good friends
major cords exist in physics they exist
in nature for example there there's a
harmonic Series in your mouth if you
go what you actually may hear is really
really notes Here in My Mouth every note
has these overtones if you yell in a
chapel or a cathedral I'd recommend
yelling in cathedrals in general it's
just actually quite a fun thing to do
but if you
go in a massive room you will hear all
those overturns shining back at you and
you hear a ma a major chord which is
crazy a minor chord which you could say
is derived from the undertone series as
opposed to the overtone series it
doesn't actually really exist in nature
in that in that exact state in a
nutshell I would say mles don't always
sound sad but perhaps one of the reasons
why they can inherently feel a little
heavier than major chords is that they
are the exact opposite in physics to
what a major chord is it's actually not
a question it's a it's a statement I
think we're entering a post riff world
all the riffs have been used up and
there are no more riffs left to be
written all new riffs are either bad or
a copy of another riff I disagree
personally yeah you think you can make
up riffs I think there are new riffs
like let's make up one right
now
right I've definitely
heard I've heard that before and I've
heard
like or something like that before
perhaps no one has collided I mean let
me know in the comments if you this riff
is taken and I won't write a song with
it but it's my ability as a riff maker
to combine things that I like that maybe
aren't normally put together that's
what's cool that's what's interesting
and that's what's worth doing so don't
be afraid to take something you like
like a riff or a cord or whatever and
make it your own in an interesting way
from at Rod goel's what makes a baseline
funky that's capital letters there what
makes a baseline funky is also a little
bit subjective but stable
[Music]
time right so just having something
that's stable that you can you can move
your body to
[Music]
repetition sit on this all
day and then making variations on that
it's it's not just the notes that you
play or when you play the notes it's
actually the duration of the notes like
how long the notes are
if I play all those notes long that is
maybe less funky in my opinion so it's
actually a
mixture see some of those notes are
[Music]
longer and and the control you have over
the length of your notes you can go a
huge distance here is another bass relay
question from uh add comfortable 8467 do
basist always tune the octave down from
the guitar the answer is fundamentally
yes Yes actually the base is essentially
tuned an ox down from an ordinary guitar
not this five string tailor but this
this is a six string tailor that I have
just stowed down here e a d g b and e
these four notes
here are the same as
[Music]
these on this base guitar here okay this
is a drum question so I'm going to
answer it here at this drum kit what are
your favorite tricks to keep your drum
tracks interest ing Andor evolving well
I think about this all the time if you
take an ordinary
beat that's one of the most legendary
beats of all time you can make that
interesting without adding any notes or
even changing any notes all I'm going to
do is I'm going to nudge certain things
forward and certain things backward say
for example I move the snare drum
backwards just a fraction this is what
that sounds
[Music]
like
and already I'm kind of
like if I move the high hat
[Music]
forwards right so it's kind of sluggish
fully all over itself one of the
absolute pioneers of this was of course
Jay dillow the legendary hip-hop
producer from around 2000 he was just
absolutely masterful at creating these
kind of recipes Sonic recipes for
grooves that had gravity in them grooves
that had momentum in them so certain
parts of the groove pulling back certain
parts of pulling forwards all that stuff
makes your drum tracks far more
interesting without having to add a
bunch of crazy fails this is from a
coral user what is four on the floor
there are a few different elements here
before me at the drums there's symbols
there are Toms there's a snare drum but
most importantly for four on the floor
is a Kick
Drum and four on the floor Every Beat of
a 44 bar is filled or anchored by a kick
so something like
this as long as those four beats are
going you're fine you can call it up on
the floor here's another question from
wallo squeegee how the hell do you count
all time signatures in music in music we
have we have these things called time
signatures within every measure or every
bar you can divide that amount of space
into a variety of different numbers so a
lot of music is is in four beats on a
bar 1 2 3 4 1 2 so if I
[Music]
go 1 2 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 that's a groov in
four if I were to go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1 2 3
4 5
[Music]
6 right 1 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 that is cool
that's a bar in 7 74 you can basically
divide time into any number of Beats or
subdivisions as you so please this is a
fun question from JPB and the question
is hey music nerds I'm trying to
understand the concept of poly Rhythm
aren't we all I've long been fascinated
with the idea of poly Rhythm poly Rhythm
just means many rhythms at once if I
play three in my left hand and five in
my right hand that sounds like
this see so 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 1 when I was
a teenager I set myself a a challenge
what if I could do five rhythms at the
same time on the fingers of one hand so
like a five-way poly Rhythm here goes
so 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 1
2 one they happen at the same time it's
funky it's fun it's cool this question
comes from Charles Welter how does a
musical piece played with unweighted
keys compare to it played with weighted
keys this is a a Nord keyboard and this
keyboard has what we call weighted keys
in the sense that when I play a note the
key is a little heavy it's actually it's
mimicking a real piano and inside of a
piano are Hammers and a hammer will hit
three strings per note many of us who
play keyboard instruments we kind of
seek that feeling there's just there's
just more degrees of nuance that you can
find it's nice to be able to lean into
the dimension of the sound now in this
drawer here what have we here we have
this lovely mini Lab 3 by artua this
keyboard is unweighted we say weighted
in the sense that the keys are light as
a
feather this can be really fun
especially if you're playing like fast
stuff you can whiz around like your
fingers don't get so tired if I whiz
around on here it just takes a bit more
muscle power this is easier to to fly
around on but it's harder to to maybe
find some of the depth to of maintain
some of the nuance and performance with
something like this here's a question
what is the difference between the White
and The Black Keys on a piano the white
keys on the piano uh are all the notes
of the c major
scales the black notes notes are all the
notes which are not in the key of C
major so there are seven notes in C
major and there are five notes that are
not in C major they're in a completely
different part of the musical key
question here from vegetable oil
underscore why does some cords sound
better together in cord progressions
than others it's a great question if I
pick up this five string guitar here
this is in the key of D so certain
chords when you're in D they sound nice
or you can say they sound Conant in D
because they have common notes so for
example the chord of G
major right does not sound too foreign
in D Major because both chords contain a
D in fact this G major I played also
contend an a cuz it had a little bit of
color in
it it's about the the notes that carry
over between cores okay do that's
everything we have time for today thanks
for such amazing questions hope you
learned something I sure did and I hope
to see you out there very soon okay
Cheerio
bye